Good morning John; I'm in Seattle and if you
don't believe me, there's a Space Needle out
the window. Come on camera. Why does it just
look white? Why is it, oop, there ya go! There
ya go, there's a Space Needle.
Now you have to adjust to me again, but that
took no time at all. What? Strange camera,
I do not understand you. On my last video
there was somebody who was like "Hank you
need to set your aperture settings to different
ones so that you are less blurry when you
move in and away from the camera!" and I said
"Oh I shall do that!" and then I did try.
I couldn't find the settings.
I am currently on a tiny mini tour of the
Pacific Northwest with Paul and Storm (Storm:
"I can talk to a camera and drive at the same
time, which can be amusing. Paul is not driving,
which is amusing as well." Paul: "I am not
driving. Do you find me amusing?") and Mike
Phirman (Mike: "Excuse me I'm just adjusting
my nutsack. What! Haha it's a pun and a prop!").
During the sound-check for me, which, I know
now because I am a muu-musician, professionally,
you get up on stage and you play the guitar
and you sing a song and I was singing "I'm
Gonna Kill You".
"I'm gonna kill you and all your loud ass
friends too!" And so they apparently need
a lot of sound check, usually its just like
duh-duh-duh-duh, sing-sing-sing-sing, and
it's over, but they're pretty pro at the place
we were at last night. And when I say last
night I mean two nights ago if you're watching
this on Friday. And Jason Finn, who is the
drummer for "The Presidents of the United
States of America" which is a band that I
totally geeked out about when I was in high
school, starts playing the drums to "I'm Gonna
Kill You" and I'm like, "Oh god Hank! Don't
screw up! Stay at the same tempo, please don't
mess up; he's playing along, just play! Just
play!" And then Paul of "Paul and Storm" is
like "This is pretty easy, it's just the same
three chords over and over again" and he starts
playin' it on the piano! And I'm like "Okay!
Sound-check has turned into dreams coming
true! Excellent!"
So now it is Thursday; I'm doing this video
today because this Friday is another show
day in Portland, Oregon! Are you from Portland,
Oregon? Are you not going to be at my show?
That is ridiculous! (Paul: "Links are in the
Doobly-Doo.")
John, I'll be honest with you for a second,
I am ashamed that I make money from advertising
because I believe that advertising is a little
bit evil. It feels that often, advertising
is there to, uh, lie to us and make us do
things that we otherwise would not. But it's
not to say that I think all advertising is
bad; I mean sometimes we should do things
that we don't want to do, and sometimes its
just about making us spend money on one thing
instead of another thing. Yeaghaghagh, I'm
sure it's not all evil.
I apologize to the people of Nerdfighteria,
but I am not going to turn off advertisements
on these videos because otherwise, I could
not make these videos. And I believe that
the good entertainment of these videos is
outweighing whatever damage the advertiser
is doing to your brain. And to my brain of
course, I also see Geico offering me up to
15% or more off on my car insurance. Up to
15% or more! Up to! 15%! Or more! You could
not create a more non-specific statement!
And then there's these new Toyota commercials
- I believe that these are very evil - in
which this ridiculous looking child is making
his dad feel guilty about having an old car.
The kid is like "I can't believe I have to
be seen in such an ugly thing!" Was that over
the top? Was that - I think that was over
the top. The moral of the story of course
being you, as a father, should be ashamed
for being poor and/or being fiscally responsible.
Y'know what Toyota? Eat it! And I'm pointing
to a corndog, it's, it's just off frame. Okay
I'm feeling a little bit better now,you're
seeing advertisements, but I'm making fun
of advertisements too, so it's cool!
So I hope that you enjoyed this video of me
rambling on the floor of a hotel; I am in
fact on the floor. Here I am. I'm on the floor,
hello.
People of Portland, I will see you on Friday.
John, I will see you on Monday!